الى تطورات على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه حيث اعلن حزب الله تنفيذه
ثمان هجمات ضد اهداف اسرائيليه وقال الحزب
انه قصف ثكنه برانيت بصاروخي فلق واحد
وادف تجمعا للجنود الاسرائيليين في تله
الكبرى ومستوطن يرون وقاعده خربه ماعر كما
قصف موقعي سماقه رمثه في مزارع شبعه
المحتله وعلن الحزب قصفه مستوطنه ايفن
مناحم ردا على الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على
منازل المدنيين في جنوب لبنان من جهتها
شنت المقاتلات الاسرائيليه غارات على
بلدات الطيبه وعت الشعب وارون وام التوت
ومنطقه جبل بلاط كما قصفت المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه بلدات حدوديه جنوبي
لبنان في المقابل اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
تنفيذ طائراته الحربيه غارات استهدفت ما
وصفها بمواقع تابعه لحزب الله في الاراضي
اللبنانيه واضاف ان القصف استهدف موقعي
مراقبه و قياده عسكريا مشيرا الى انه رصد
اطلاق ثلاث قذائف صاروخيه استهدفت شمالي
اسرائيل وسقطت في مناطق مفتوحه دون وقوع
اصابات